we are asked which expression can we use
to find the missing number in the
pattern so pause this video and see if
you can try this before we do this
together
all right
now let's try this together and the way
i would tackle it is i'll try to see hey
can i figure out the pattern between
these numbers and then i could try to
figure out the missing one so to go from
36 to 45 it looks like i'm increasing by
9 so i add 9
and it looks like to go from 63 to 72
we're adding 9. it's good to make sure
that the pattern that you think is
happening is happening across all of the
numbers that you're seeing and to go
from 72 to 81 it looks like you're
adding 9. so i'm pretty confident that
to go from 45 to this blank number i
have to add 9
and we see here indeed choice b is 45
plus 9. that this number here you don't
even have to figure out what it is some
of you might realize it's 54.
but this is just going to be this number
plus 9 is going to go in the blank so 45
plus 9. let's do another example
so here it's a little bit different it
says if the pattern continues what will
be the sixth number in the pattern pause
this video and try to figure that out
all right so first let's figure out the
pattern to go from two to six it looks
like we added four then we are adding
four again to go from six to ten then
we're adding four again to go from 10 to
14 so it seems like we're adding 4 every
time and this is the first 1 2 3
4 numbers in the pattern so the fifth
number in the pattern is going to be 14
plus 4 which is going to be 18 and then
the sixth number in the pattern is going
to be 18 plus 4 which is 22 and that's
what they want they want the sixth
number in the pattern so 22 is choice d
let's do another example
here we're told the table below shows
the number of laps carly ran around the
track each day
which rule describes the pattern shown
by the number of laps carly ran
so like always pause this video and see
if you could work on this
all right it seems like every time a day
goes by the number of laps are going up
by three
so
if you want to figure out the next day
let's say day six
you would add three from day five so the
pattern here is to add three